why don't because in my head like  why wouldn't you avoid this if you could  go back you wouldn't avoid the  situations because you I thought in the  beginning you said that like you  wouldn't change it because of the wisdom  you've acquired but to me it's like oh  my God if I if I knew what I know now  like I probably I probably would have  waited till I was married no I can I I  get that and I understand that I think  that  I have a very influential voice and I  have grown to be a voice for women who  have gone through what I've gone through  and experienced what I've experienced  and  although I again I can't speak for the  majority because my situation still  isn't even average right and I'm aware  of that but my voice is important just  like your voice is important and that's  why I don't I would not want to change  anything